-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with my co-host,
Jack Harlow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, since you're starring
in the upcoming remake
of "White Men Can't Jump,"
I thought I'd put
your skills to the test
in a "Random Object Shootout,"
okay?
Are you gonna kill me at this?
-We'll see.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I feel good.
-Yeah.
Here's how this works.
We're gonna take turns
trying to shoot random objects
into that hoop behind us.
If you make it in,
you get a point.
Let's see
what our first object is.
It is...
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
...a jack-o-lantern.
Okay.
-Who's shooting first?
-Uh, well, you're my guest,
so maybe...
You want me to go first?
-It has some weight to it.
-Yeah, I know.
It's got a little heft.
You can --
You can toss it like that.
-But I can let it fly.
You don't care about
what happens, anything?
-Well, as long as it's
towards the hoop, yeah, yeah.
-That's what I mean.
[ Laughter ]
-I want the audience to be safe.
-This is the spot?
-Yeah, that's --
Well, you can go up here.
You can go up here.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Sad tuba ]
Smashed the pumpkin.
All right now --
-All right, bend your knees.
Bend your knees.
-All right.
♪♪
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Come on.
-Thank you for the tip.
All right.
Let's see the second object.
Cornucopia full of eyeballs.
Here we go.
Now, I think, for this,
you actually have
to get the cornucopia,
the basket, in the basket,
really.
Don't worry about the eyeballs
so much.
That's just spooky
for spooky season.
-By all means.
-Really?
-That's so nice.
Thank you, bud.
♪♪
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Sad tuba ]
Sad?
-It's all right.
-[ Laughs ]
-You were so disappointed in me
right there.
♪♪
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's skill!
That's skill right there!
That's skills.
All right.
The third object --
-Hold on.
-That stays in there.
That's good.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Third object is...
a vase full of applesauce.
[ Audience groans ]
It's apple-picking season.
You can do a bunch of
different things with apples.
Applesauce is one of them.
♪♪
You ready?
-Who's first?
-I think you should go first.
You're the one
who sank the basket.
♪♪
Just be careful.
Be care-- Don't worry.
-I don't want this on me.
-It won't hurt anybody.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can we see that again?
Whoa!
Swish!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And my cornucopia
is still in there.
-Exactly!
[ Laughter ]
Dude.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
♪♪
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughter ]
All right...
-What a mess.
-Clean up is gonna be tough.
It's all right.
We're gonna be all right.
-I'm sure you won't be involved.
-We're going to be --
I'll help out.
Don't go anywhere near there,
all right?
All right.
I had some extra muscle --
All right, here we go.
This one right here, this is...
Oh, this is Necco wafers.
This is something that Jack --
-Are they edible?
-Yeah, they're candy --
famous candies
that no kid wants to get
on Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
So, we got all the Halloween --
we're gonna do it now.
How's it taste?
-Good.
-Yeah, right.
All right, ready for this?
-Middle-of-the-road candy.
-Thank you.
Necco wafers, here we go.
-Whoo!
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Someone gave me a "whoo."
Someone threw me off
with their "whoo."
Someone said, "Whoo!"
All right, bud.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-It's the cheers.
[ Laughter ]
-It looks actually pretty good
with my applesauce splatter.
Actually looks kind of festive
and gorgeous.
All right.
Now, look, guys,
it is time for the moneyball.
-Imagine what's in here.
-This is worth --
This is worth 5 points,
so whoever sinks this wins,
okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is a Mike Myers...
-That ain't right.
-Jack, you go first.
Good luck.
♪♪
It's a Michael Myers head
from "Halloween."
-This is actually --
-Not bad?
You think you can do it?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
I mean,
are you kidding me, man?
You know what?
I gotta be honest --
-I got all my [bleep] in there.
[ Laughter ]
Everything I own.
I'm gonna throw my phone
in there.
-No, don't throw your phone
Oh, my --
You know what?
I hurt my wrist a little bit
on that last one.
[ Laughter ]
-You want me to shoot yours?
-No, I think I'm gonna have
someone else take my shot.
Please welcome three-time NBA
champion and executive producer
of the new Netflix documentary
"The Redeem Team,"
Dwyane Wade, right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo,
you're gonna be all over it.
All over it.
[ Both laugh ]
-Come on, bud.
-I thought it was gonna be like,
I get to make the only shot.
-Yeah, exactly.
He's perfect right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They love you.
You don't have to make this.
This is just --
I just appreciate you
just being here.
Nothing you could do.
You can shoot from up here,
whatever you feel like, Dwyane,
but it's up to you, bud.
♪♪
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
Dude --
-I thought it was going in.
-I'm wet.
-That was never gonna happen.
-That's never gonna happen.
That's amazing.
-My serve was too tight.
I couldn't go --
-You're the best, bud.
Come on, you're the best.
That's what I'm talking about.
Dwyane Wade, Jack Harlow.
The champ!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to Jack and Dwyane
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!